Kobe Bryant when he retired he told his
daughters he said if you get this you'll
have a successful life and he had all
his his trophies he had all his
accolades and he said this isn't the
dream he said the dream was waking up 5
a.m getting to the gym when nobody else
was getting it the dream was going back
getting 500 shots and what he said was
if you fall in love with that and
understand that's the real dream getting
to do this every day those results will
start taking fruition as a result I
always tell people everybody's like an
All or Nothing yep but it's like if you
move it one percent every day what would
mean moving this project one percent in
about three and a half months hundred
days yeah it'll be 100 further long a
lot of people go all in one day I'm
excited and then you don't hear from
them for weeks you want to take a guy
you want to take his company from 500
million to a billion my first question
is and what do we need to do it's who do
you need to be and then we work
backwards from a way of being and how do
we create the best way of Being for the
people out there in the world is to
start working on their thoughts thoughts
turn emotions emotions turn to behaviors
Behavior turn the result the most
dangerous words in the human language is
nobody will know but me you know I was
committed to doing that thing for the
project today nobody on note of me yeah
I thought I was going to go to the gym
today nobody will know but me you really
start creating a low-grade kind of way
of being now one of the highest
frequency words are I am so we want to
be careful the words that come after I
am I am tired I am overwhelmed because
then you start looking at a life that
looks like tired and overwhelmed
what you're about to watch is a sample
from my movement makers training it's
where I train thought leaders to build
their movement make an income have an
impact around the world I train in the
group twice a month and start to bring
in my friends as well to share their
expertise and wisdom if you want to join
us movement makers is the link in
description below and for now enjoy this
clip we got a special guest in the house
Devin bandison so we're going to talk
coaching today and this man
is a legend in the coaching space he's
worked with the NBA Major League
Baseball Executives entrepreneurs it's a
six-figure price tag to work with them
up to up to 200 000 a year maybe that's
gone up I don't know but he's a legend
thanks for having me man it's great to
be here I love it what's up movement
makers I got the New York accent in the
house I love it let's touch coaching
methodology you are working with some of
the highest of high achievers so it's
not people who are trying to figure out
their way in life and trying to get
started it's like these people have
already had a ton of success they
recognize the value of coaching and now
you're coming into taking them to the
next level yeah what is if you had the
high level how do you how do you coach
people what's your methodology what do
you work people through yeah yeah it's
great question you know Evan a lot of
people when you go around the space
there's a lot of confusion around
coaching because everyone and their
mothers sometimes are calling themselves
a coach right so you know and and
there's a lot of times where for me when
I work with people uh there's no the
agenda is the person in front of me
right so I need to get in their world I
don't come with my agenda I have
different ways I work with people but I
really need to find out who's in front
of me and and I think a lot of times
people want like give me this just tell
me what to do give me the seven step
ways to drink water in Arizona right
like like they all have like the you
know this five ways to to move to Costa
Rica and if you just tell me what to do
then I'll have what I want and then I'll
be happy and be successful
or people if you grew up in the 70s they
say if I just have if I just have the
right environment if I just have the
right relationship then I'll do the
right thing and then and only then will
I be happy is that a 70 singer I don't
know well have a doobie all right right
so so it's like so it's like a lot of
the time while life has been spent doing
and having but it's left us a default
way of being so I don't work on do have
B when I first get someone or have to be
what I do is I work with people on being
if you want to be if a guy comes to me
and says I want to average 25 points a
game and he's averaging 13. my first
question isn't what do we need to do
because all the the skills are there the
the strategy what we have to do will
show up my first question is who do you
need to be if you want to take a guy you
want to take his company from 500
million to a billion my first question
is and what do we need to do it's who do
you need to be and then we work
backwards from a way of being and how do
we how do we create the best way of
Being for the people out there in the
world is to start working on their
thoughts thoughts turn emotions emotions
turn to behaviors behaviors turn the
results if I got you know 3.6 million
subscribers on YouTube but I want to get
the 35 million yeah who do I need to be
it's a great question who is the person
I need to be to be the person who brings
it to the next level so it's like you
know what Devin I need to be someone
with a higher level of commitment I need
to be someone who my word and integrity
is non-negotiable I need to be and then
we work on any thought lights limiting
beliefs that will get in the way of that
way of being because neuroplasticity is
shown us through the studies is that you
could literally rewire your thoughts and
the patterns of your brain right but
what happens is we get caught up in the
same patterns every day so it's like I
wake up I break a glass most people say
I'm gonna have a bad day okay right and
then what happens they get on the
parkway this it's uh traffic but there's
traffic every day but they say see the
brain begins to look for evidence so
what we do is we start with the thoughts
we rewire the thoughts so then the
behaviors and emotions thought okay so
if we use me as a in getting in front of
everybody which is great let's go so so
who do I need to be how do I how do I
answer that question what would you ask
me next yeah so who do you need to be so
where are you now with your subscribers
so if at 3.6 million yeah
how do I get to 35 35 that's the next
goal yeah yeah let's paint a picture
okay so a year from now you and I are
sitting in Arizona let's go all right
and we're looking back over the last
year yeah and you say Devin I can't
believe it ever since I last I taught
last year and this has been the most
extraordinary jumping subscribers of my
life this has been the best year of my
life okay tell me what is talk to me
from that place
like tell me what has occurred over the
last year
I have
let go of
the projects that
uh are smaller that have been chewing up
more of my time or I've assigned them to
people on the team to take over and I've
filled them with
higher opportunities
uh deeper water fishing
to catch the bigger fish
kind of strategies tell me more about
that projects that uh
take longer to go and execute that have
a much higher uh rate of potential
return but also more risk attached to it
that some days you may feel like you're
making zero progress towards these
bigger goals
but that could move the needle in a much
further away than just keep doing the
same thing that I'm doing perfect so if
you let go of these lower hanging fruits
and you focus on
you know the big game the main the main
thing
how is your life better what has
occurred as a result of that
over the last year that was my life
better wow I don't know if my life is
better how's my life better result of
having 35 million subscribers
um I think my my business is definitely
better how's your business better allows
me to have more impact more reach
um
feel like I'm
I'm doing you know or stepping more into
what I'm capable of doing yeah and in
that moment of making a bit big impact
and you see in the impact you're making
yeah right you're feeling like you're
making an impact who are you being right
there like what does it feel like who is
that guy right there that's a it's a
it's a better event yeah it's uh it's uh
it's like this is my purpose and I'm
stepping into it yeah so we don't need
to wait a year to have a better edit
yeah right we need to we you have heard
of a declaration we need to be that now
okay we need to be the guys
right declare you ever heard a
declaration what is it called
Declaration of
independent Independence yes I'm
Canadian yeah yeah
guess what yeah there wasn't
Independence when there was a
declaration let's go
let's go there was an independence it
was a declaration that they lived into
so we need to declare right it's not an
affirmation it's a declaration and then
we create a way of being a thought
process that you're already living at
throughout this next year okay a way of
being declare live into as a go-to my
coach in the NBA before I didn't go on
indeed.com and there we go I could play
at it and lived into it right y'all with
me so so we want to declare that Evan
right 35 million subscribers yeah making
an impact being the best version of Evan
now yeah so when we go to this meeting
later you're walking in that meeting
with that way of being what does it look
like what does it sound like how does it
how do you how do you stand how do you
sit right now if that didn't happen What
would be the reason we got to next year
was sitting in front of movement makers
if it didn't happen What would be the
reason you guys are going to be my
accountability uh buddies collectively
here listen up movement make it's gonna
be my accountability buddies uh okay if
that if that didn't happened what would
be the reason either you know projects
are taking longer than anticipated
um not not making enough progress not
meeting the right people not uh you know
not moving the things along as quickly
as I'd like or I got sidetracked or I
didn't live up to the Declaration on a
daily basis yeah so who do you need to
be
to be committed to living into that
declaration every day
what's two things you're committed to
start doing two things you committed to
stop doing start doing is cutting out
some of those 80 like figure out what is
what is what are those things I need to
eliminate okay by when I mean starting
today but when's it going to finish it's
an ongoing process
but give yourself some markers okay it's
like start today look I always tell
people everybody's like an all or
nothing yeah but it's like if you move
it one percent every day just one
percent it's like what would me move in
this project one percent in about three
and a half months hundred days yeah
it'll be 100 further long yep a lot of
people go all in one day I'm more I'm
excited and then you don't hear from
them for weeks yeah so we want to create
see the dream is not the outcome it's
not the 35 million subscribers The Dream
is the process the dream you know Kobe
Bryant when he retired he told his his
daughters he said if you get this you'll
have a successful life and he had all
his his trophies he had all his
um accolades and he said this isn't the
dream he said the dream was waking up 5
a.m getting to the gym when nobody else
was getting the dream was going back
getting 500 shots and what he said was
if you fall in love with that and
understand that's the real dream getting
to do this every day those results the
35 million will start taking taking
fruition as a result and on the process
of that the most important thing is who
is Evan being because if Evan's being a
3.5 million guy walking into rooms you
won't see the opportunity of the 35
million right in front of you does that
make sense yeah yeah so
one percent every day get a commitment
all right what's another thing you're
committed to start to what's the one so
one percent every day as a as a
awareness yeah it's like when you when
you what do I do right say you're stuck
it's like oh it's I'm not moving around
it's like what would moving this along
one percent today look like just at
least one percent now you could do more
than one percent but that's how you can
stay committed to your declarations your
commitments because a lot of people they
get frustrated they get distracted but
one percent is doable no matter what day
it no matter what's going on here right
world so you want to have that one
commitment of clearing out the 80
percent every day as as a commitment I'm
gonna move this along one percent today
does that make sense yeah yeah okay well
then I would add to that the that's the
eliminating of the the smaller projects
and then I would pair that with the
effort towards the bigger projects yeah
now is there in your mind a time frame
where you want to create that line
create the bigger projects yet eliminate
the smaller projects
um again like it's an ongoing it's an
ongoing thing I like the one percent
every day because it's an everyday
because what what what today's small
projects are where a year ago is like
big projects right right so it's like
it's an ongoing shedding of the skin as
you grow correct right correct so
there's no like there's no one project
that I wish oh my gosh I wish I didn't
have to do this thing yeah I I think my
challenge is I actually like a lot of
those little things yeah I like the
process so much that I keep doing it
even though I probably shouldn't be
doing it anymore right
see so you want to look at that you want
to look at the shiny object it's like
you're so powerful and you you have such
a voice for the world that we want to
highlight your greatness right where you
can make the most impact where you can
really make it dip the most impact in
the world and when you're getting caught
up here it's it's cheating the world
yeah it's cheating people stop being
stingy stop being stop being selfish
Michael stop being selfish no I have to
remind myself of that because I could
get lost in just a full day of
responding to YouTube comments yeah
because it's so fun and meaningful it's
like know that I helped somebody and
just stay in the YouTube but then I'm
not
creating that's right
there's a guy
um who uh was a childhood not Mentor but
he was he was a friend of the family uh
his name was Tony and he was in politics
and one of the things that he did every
day was he would go every day to his
constituency and knock on doors and talk
to people every day and I I used to
think well that's like that's a great
thing to do and he always won his little
area but
when he ran for the leadership of the
party for the whole province uh he got
smoked because the work he was doing was
too small every day he was one of the
hardest working guys in in in the game
right but just doing the wrong work
but he loved it and so I like I remind
myself that daily commit was like don't
be Tony because I could easily get stuck
in Tony world was like I'm just gonna
respond to every message and every DM
and every comment and because that's why
I do what I do but then I'm I feel the
great I feel the uh the low hanging
fruit of like I helped that one person
help that one person which then prevents
me from then doing the bigger work the
the deeper work the bigger projects of
correct you know in the morning uh when
I when I do uh three questions I ask
it's like three things I'm grateful for
three things that would make today
extraordinary right so I trained the
brain to look for Extraordinary right
like because the brain looks for
evidence right so for me when people ask
me you know how you're doing my answer
is always the same I check in it's the
best day of my life and I don't mean
it's not like a uh like people say
living the dream it's not that it's like
I'm committed I don't wait for
circumstances for this to be the best
day of my life I declare it and live
into it now the third question is what
is my MIT for the day what's the most
important thing that if I move this
forward if I move this forward I know
I'm moving towards that big goal that I
want to have so and usually what I'll do
is the two at one to three mits I do
that in the first 90 minutes of my day
I get that so by 10 o'clock I always say
I've done a lot more than most people do
all day because I got the most that
thing isn't hanging in my head because
I've been on you know responding to a
lot of emails I commit that time early
to get my mits move forward and then I'm
into the day just being with the world
so kind of around that one of the things
I found helpful is having different
things on different days yeah so like
Thursday this is normal where it's on a
Thursday here some of my public facing
day so normally an interview child like
don't talk to people uh but I always
start Thursdays with like movement
makers or one of my trainings and then
I'm doing interviews and podcasts all
day long because I could easily again
get stuck and just respond in the
comments yeah all day long and so it's
like the maybe it's the little dopamine
hit maybe it's the validation of what
I'm doing maybe it's just a feeling good
of like oh I'm I'm helping most of the
time I'm just at my home in Toronto with
my wife you know yeah chilling doing my
thing so it's hard to imagine maybe
sometimes
the Declaration of something much bigger
but it's always easy to get into the
comments and see what correct impacts
it's like this little tiny Impact versus
the bigger one so that's why we want to
set up a a system for you to declare it
have that be clear who that guy is who
you're being like I tell the guy the guy
on average 12 is not going to be the guy
who averages 25 and my guy ended up
making the All-Star I was 23 and came
short right now but that's who we you
when you keep that as an awareness you
live into that every day see I have a
declaration and I'm at the airport
people ask me like who are you and I say
to him do you want to know who I am or
do you want to know my name two
different questions okay if they tell me
I want to know who you are I then say
well do you have about four minutes and
30 seconds because I have declared I
have a four minute 30 second Declaration
of who I am okay right and so what that
does is I have trained my brain I knew
who was going to be in this room before
he got here okay I'm not wishy-washy I
go here I'm one way I'm here that way I
know who I am because I declare it each
day are these like airport security
people are like this is everybody okay I
talk to everybody you'll get to know me
Starbucks people uh everybody airport
security everybody but airport security
is asking who are you I have to say well
I got my name
yeah so so it's like look a lot of
people have have lived into things
called you know two things the most
dangerous words of the human language in
my opinion or the not two words most
dangerous words in the human language is
nobody will know but me um you know I
was committed to doing that thing for
the project today nobody on note of me
yeah I thought I was going to go to the
gym today nobody will know about me you
really start creating a low-grade yeah
kind of way of being now one of the
highest frequency words are I am so we
want to be careful the words that come
after I am I am tired I am overwhelmed
because then you start looking at a life
that looks like tired and overwhelmed so
my declaration is four minutes and 30
seconds it's like I am love I'm the
Divine Light That illuminates every room
I enter I'm a miracle like I live into
every day the power of that vibration it
reminds me that Henry Ford quote the
quality is doing it right when nobody
else is watching Bingo 100
I have a question for you okay so we got
one thing you're committed to yeah
what's one thing you're committed to
stop doing today
well we have two things I'm 22 right
yeah okay
one thing that I'm committed to stop
doing is starting with the small stuff
I mean it's still I guess related to the
the one percent better or I'm going for
the deeper projects but yeah you know I
stopped being 3.5 million of it there
you go there you go because 3.5 million
out of it isn't 30. doesn't get 35 yeah
so you might want to when you got
movement makers like oh you when you
come in it's like hey I'm 35 million uh
subscriber Evan hold him to that are
y'all willing to hold them to that
like that declaration
I like it yeah I like it I know I know
some people who are already going to be
uh messaging me and uh saying Evan how
you doing today yeah look at all the
guesses oh yeah yeah
because what happens is you'll raise
your vibration and things will start you
ever heard of the zone right yep being
in the flow and we've been taught like
we got to get in this all but the Zone
actually is our Natural State but we've
been over trained and overeducated so
much that we're constantly out of the
Zone yeah right so when when I work with
athletes or or um
business owners and they're in flow or
Zone I ask them you know what what is it
no matter what sport or what profession
I said what does it feel like you know
what they don't say it was hard you know
what they don't say I was overthinking
they say things like the game started
looking easy yes the business meeting
was easy right the game slowed down
right now or the business meeting I
could hear things that people weren't
saying because it slowed down and it
wasn't that it slowed down physically it
was like they were so present they were
so present and in the moment that
everything flows and if you're being
that in the moment 35 million subscriber
that not it's not about the number of
subscribers for you I know you yeah it's
about it's really about the impact you
make on the world and you have such a
gift that we don't want to cheat the
world from that gift man yep no that's
that's a that's a great reminder like
for myself
um that I feel like I'm doing a service
by doing the smaller stuff and that I'm
cheating the world of me doing more yeah
because it's like the the easy path to
uh what is it what's the code about the
uh you don't hit your big goals because
you find an easier path to a lesser goal
yeah right yeah it's like okay to sit in
the discomfort of not knowing or
slowness to go for the deeper waters
versus I'm just gonna go help this one
person that's it right but the reminder
that uh I'm not doing the best that I
can't yeah yeah so you're a big game
player and it's not an ego thing no I
hear an impact thing 100 John Wooden
said if you win the game
and didn't play your best you didn't
really win the game if you lose the game
but played your best you didn't really
lose the game yeah because it's all
about Evan stepping into the highest
version and biggest impact he can make
yeah like if you want to race against
three-year-old two characters back Bingo
yeah so what's the most valuable thing
you're hearing in this conversation for
you well I'll give you my initial
thoughts because I probably have to
re-watch as Yale back through it you
know it's like the live experience uh
no the the willingness to
um
recognize that I I should be doing
something else you know like I I'm
cheating the world if I'm not doing the
bigger projects yeah because it's
because it it's like good as the enemy
of great if I was sitting at home just
playing video games or something okay
obviously I'm not doing the thing but I
I tricked myself to say I'm I'm serving
by answering comments and doing stuff
right it's not planning to completely
stop answering comments but reminding
myself that I could be doing something
more valuable with my time than what I
currently am yeah yeah and it's all the
the good to great well great to
Stratosphere because you're already
great it's like how do we go great to
stratospheric it's like
commitment and failure to commit I fully
commit is the high cost of low living
so if you look at areas of your life
where it's not you know you're
struggling or it's like I know I should
be doing this and that it's not because
something's wrong it's because the the
commitment is not as high as others so
we want to raise the commitment because
failure to commit is the high cost of
low limit now one thing in language I'm
a big language guy okay right I have
words called benchmar words benchwormer
yeah you know like you know how do you
like the words on this side don't don't
I love it it came in you got me beat I
was like dang I should have won by
myself yeah he's the man he's and he's
the real dad did you meet everybody in
person this guy in person just lights up
a room so yeah y'all got the best
um you know bench one words or words
that like you know Benchwarmers and they
call it Benchwarmers because they sit on
the bench they never get in the game you
know yeah and they and yeah and if you
sit in their seat it's warm because
their butt been there so long right so
there's bench warmer words that will
keep us exhausted one of the words that
we want to start getting rid of is the
word should
okay I should you know I know I should
go to the gym I should move this forward
because it really it it will exhaust you
shouldn't don't on yourself don't
shoot on others they should like I wish
she would act different but that isn't
going to help you yeah right I wish I
should go to the I should go to the gym
no get committed to going to the gym
okay get committed to stepping into this
new way of being okay so we want to get
rid of the word should another word I'll
give you is do you know who the first
executive life coach in the world was no
guy named Yoda okay let's go Luke was
talking to yodie y'all remember and and
he said I'm gonna try to do it yo then
Yoda said look do or do not there is no
try right so we want to give it a try
it's like if you said Devin can you meet
me tomorrow for for
um for lunch I said well I'm gonna try
to get there yeah not admit it yeah so
so some of these words should try we
want to start getting out of our
language and getting okay yeah
so I said should in uh what what yeah
your placement for me in there yeah it's
like I'm gonna commit to okay you know
what I mean like not even not even I'm
going to commit to yeah I'm gonna I am I
am committed too I am is going to is
still that's right yeah it's kind of we
leave we we let ourselves off the hook
yeah and you're too powerful to keep
letting yourself off the hook because in
in your world and and a lot of you on
the screen it's like
your 80 this is this is the danger all
of people like the movement makers and
you guys run into and you're 80 looks
like most people's 100 oh yeah yeah
right and that can keep us playing small
yeah yeah yeah for sure I mean fifty
percent right most people most people
are doing almost nothing right yeah for
sure all right this guy is he's the New
Yoda I love it it's great okay well I'm
taking a lot from this I'm committed to
doing the work there you go good I'm
already switching and create and be
committed to who you're gonna be the guy
who's gonna be there a year from now
having that conversation you know I'm
gonna be more joyful in the impact I
make I'm gonna be more you know in
inclusive meaning I have a lot of people
that that are able to access me in
different ways not the same ways be that
person
good job let's talk about pricing and
increasing your pricing there's so many
people who are coaching now so many
people call themselves a life coach
you're out there actually doing it you
know up to 200 000 a year to work with
you how do you price yourself how do you
Market yourself how do you kind of get
to that level I took a maybe a
non-traditional route I've never really
when I came in marketed myself right I I
learned from some of the best in the
business I read a book called The
prosperous coach which was by a guy
named Steve Janna and and it was the
first book I read that was like wow like
I can actually make a prosperous life by
serving people by getting in people's
world and serving people so you know I
that as I started building my business I
would I would it was one person at a
time and then uh Word of Mouth spread
and uh you know I have a wait list until
next year and it's all from referrals
and renewals you know now there's
another level for me to go from there
obviously because this is to me
transformation and business building is
a mountain with no top you never arrive
right but over the years the one way to
really build a sustainable business is
one first learn to be a really great
coach right because everybody sometimes
at every picnic and barbecue are like
a coach right so you wanna the best
coaches from my experience in the world
because there's certifications
everywhere that you can pay fifty
dollars and I'm not against
certifications but I know that from my
experience the best coaches I've seen in
the world
all have one thing in common they have
coaches it's like an apprenticeship kind
of profession it's like if if you came
to me and I was a doctor and I said EV
you need to get shoulder surgery and you
said Devin would you get that shoulder
surgery no no no I wouldn't get it but
you should get it you'd run the other
way yeah and it's the same thing in this
professional coaching
um and how you know I scaled prices is
is by value it's like when I became full
limitation creates value right so I live
in Queens and I have a place in Florida
and Scotland and and in Queens if if I
go about 15 minutes down my road there's
guys who are day laborers right and I
walk every morning and I look I I come
from a black father white mother and I
came out looking Spanish so everybody
everybody's always trying to talk to me
in Spanish and I'm like I I shouldn't
learned Spanish a little better but I'm
Poquito right so so when I walk when I
walk past the day laborers like we
connect even though I don't speak
Spanish like I always sometimes I'll
bring them Donuts sometimes I'll bring
them coffee and I just keep walking on
my morning walk but I watch
and the day labor is you know they'll be
haggling 75 100 when the trucks come
along to do landscaping for that day
right they have that everywhere right
now I also I work with a company and and
my client he has five offices on his
floor and all of them make 750k before
bonuses all of them what's the
difference between
the day laborers 100 and the guy is 700.
so what they do on this floor is they're
coding they have these special ways they
code what's the difference between the
day laborers and these guys
yeah I mean they're both working hard
correct but they work on different
things different things and the
difference is if I wanted to cut my lawn
I could cut my lawn less people in the
world can do with these the my client
does if you put me and I would cut my
law if you put me in the office for days
I'd never be able to code right so
because there's less people in the world
who could do that their value is high
and that's how I am in the coaching
industry I you know I've worked and I'm
I'm a consistent student as well as a
teacher so for me as my um practice
Began full I never stop I kept learning
I kept growing and because nobody in the
world could do what I can do the way I
do it that's how my value has been so
high that's how I created value I love
it yeah let's get some some people up
let's see let's watch Devin do his magic
on you guys so such as me why don't we
start with Zane I've been coaching for a
while and pretty good at it I find that
a lot of coaches they get so caught up
in the art of coaching they don't take
care of the business side of coaching
and the business out of coaching maybe
because how our brains are wired the
business side of coaching trips them up
so it goes back to marketing and I you
know again I kind of looked at what you
what you have going on on Devin and it's
very impressive I mean you got your game
changer package and you got what lives
coming up in New York LA and in London
and you got your one-on-one coaching you
got two different packages from the Hall
of Fame all the way up to the live
um this is the live game winner yeah and
and then I saw that come back to 85k so
part of my question is I guess you
developed those programs as you went
along throughout the years and you say
they do much marketing so price word of
mouth and referrals how did you get that
in through the referrals yeah no it was
a great question so my best marketing is
my conversations with people now there's
there's other things where you know I've
posted over the years and had some some
information out there in in the world
but like for me when I was scaling up my
game change experience which we've had
27 they've all 27 the last 27 have been
sold out and and like you said they're
all over the world
um it really started with my service
like I was in rooms like I'm I'm with
Evan and really getting in people world
and and connecting and offering in the
beginning I used to offer like
conversations with people and I would in
the conversations and and I would say
these people would come to the game
changer and then my question is like
people would get this amazing
transformational experience and then I
would hold them accountable and say like
who do you like who are you going to be
a stand for in the world and then what
happened was it started enrolling itself
right so my best marketing was like when
when people would get on conversations
with me or they'd get in the room with
me we'd have them be a stand and they
started filling these rooms kind of just
by their experience so if you give
someone a great experience if you give
someone a great experience a lot of
people there's two things one sometimes
they want to keep you as a secret weapon
you want to encourage them to go like no
go be a stand for someone else like Liz
because someone was a stand for you to
be in this room you heard about me from
someone or somehow and a med gave
someone else access so a lot of the
people who've been in my community have
really been
um have have really had such
Transformations that they go out in the
world and they're my best marketers
because I serve them so powerfully now
that doesn't mean I don't I'm not
against certain kind of marketing right
like there's stuff that goes out in in
the social media platforms that you know
my team sends out
um and you know this guy's uh like the
best in the business and and really
getting your voice out there in the
world of uh you know
thought leadership and marketing but I
but I do think that you're right coaches
get caught up too much on the auto
coaching it's important to become a
great coach and not the business of
coaching and this is a profession so
when I when I I treat my professional
part just as much as I uh as important
as I treat the art of coaching and how I
do that is I have professional days in
which I just focus like a couple days a
week on my business on way up with
Darwin where we're Scala and how we
getting the word out things like that
and and that's that's kind of has been
my journey so just just to confirm for
myself a little Clarity so are you
saying because I'm kind of relate it to
me being when I'm not when I guess I
still am a celebrity DJ but when I was
in the DJ business in an entertainment
business I'm here at like regular
clients but the only way I get the
celebrity clients was I was referred
from someone who's VIP or executive once
I did one celebrity event there's other
celebrities at the event say Hey listen
I need to they pull my college to do
like that it was just became more of a
word about referral thing it was never
like they found me by advertising I
would get a personal phone call and it's
like okay I need to come do my wedding
or come do my event
and it's like it's a small almost like a
small world referrals so I always wanted
to find out your process because if you
were in the NBA you just don't show them
say hey I'm a coach it has to be to this
level there has to be a way of going
about doing it what you said earlier
about OPP you know being being a DJ Opp
from 90s other people's platforms so
you'll get in other people's platforms
and now you're being exposed to a
different audience and there's someone
in the audience that might I pick you
out or go to your like your
apprenticeship program for 85k yeah so I
was just wondering because we all have
different processes but you're at the
highest level so I wonder what I said
the highest level and what is their
process and I think you kind of is that
kind of what you did yeah so then so
it's it's and I'm not one is not better
than the other I'm just telling you my
past so so yeah I'm not saying that
advertising and marketing doesn't help
but but what happens is a lot of coaches
go do that early but they're not really
serving people well they they haven't
really become really powerful and that's
where the conversation with Evan around
who I'm being is very important because
if you look at your highest referral
sources or your highest paid clients
right usually they come from a small
referral Outlet like someone you served
who knows someone every keynote I've
ever done most of them I would now
people have heard of me but in the
beginning every keynote I ever did was
someone I served in that company who
said hey coming we're having a
conference we'd like you to come to
Salesforce or whatever it is right look
you want to do that it's not either or
it can be both but what we want to do is
we want to strengthen our referral tree
really serve people and then that is how
like you said as a celebrity DJ you got
into different rooms now it's your job
when you get into different rooms my
best marketing
um tool is me because when I'm in a role
I'm gonna light up the room not just
because that's what I do every day I
practice a way of being so G when I'm
here with Evan I knew who was going to
be here so the conversations I'm gonna
have is going to be extraordinary and
then I can invite people to the game
changer or I don't need anything for
anybody I'm here to really be of service
and so for you Zen you're powerful
brother you're the same way you're a
break what you're a bright light so what
you want to do is serve people and then
also have your people who you're working
with who do they know who can get you
where you want to go
closed mouth don't forget fed as my
grandma used to say I love it okay one
last and let's go serve everybody I
promise one last quick question and and
then we go to the next person but I
think this is gonna serve everyone you
have different levels of plans so we
lost different levels for this game and
and how do you get them
is it could you talk about mindset be
doing half and the focus and things such
as that how do you get them to make that
tweak
they only have the skill set obviously
they already have the competence it's
just get confidence to the next level
how do you get them to get because I the
questions you asked Evan was so
confirming based on what he already said
I thought it was wonderful questions how
do you get your class to go to that next
level
so that they can have that output that
we do have the more you be the more you
the more you do the more you have to get
that output how do you have to become
more yeah
great questions so the the first thing
that comes to mind is listening
okay people don't have a powerful
listening they haven't already always
listening meaning I already heard this I
always they start finishing sentences
great coaches are the best listeners and
the quality of the results people get
are not on the answers they have it's on
the questions the quality of the results
you get is based on the quality of
questions you ask so I just have a
really powerful listening and a really
powerful way of asking questions and you
know I'm a big believer like especially
in coaching if someone tries to tell you
hey come to me I'm gonna give you the
answer run the other way because for me
my job is to point people back to the
real where the answer really is the real
source which is right there back in Evan
right back in you so how I get there is
through really powerful listening and Co
end questions let's bring up Kelly I am
a fitness professional nutrition coach I
work for like Time Fitness in North
Dallas I love my job I love serving
people but I want to play a bigger game
I want to scale my business by by and
that's why I join movement makers and
Evan's Mastermind because I want to grow
my online presence
in these four walls I can only touch the
people that walk in the door but with
the leverage of the internet and being
able to reach in in numbers so any
thoughts on me playing a bigger game
where I can take my message and reach
whether it's doing group coaching at
companies to where I'm doing I mean a
workably month shop to
50 people or 500 people be a zoom or I
mean I just see so much scale potential
by utilizing the power of the internet
any thoughts on that
well my first thought is you're you're
with the right person right because
because if anybody's gonna show you how
to scale using your voice in in the
world on on the internet and especially
YouTube is Evan so I think that you're
in the right area now
you know we don't want to wait right and
sometimes we have a vision and we think
this is what it'll look like and we
think of the biggest vision of it which
is great but like I would encourage you
to start like where you're at so you're
working in Lifetime right now correct
yes yes
and and when you talk about groups tell
me more like what what would you like to
do in regards to say groups like what
are you envisioning so for example I
have a six-month program that I do with
individuals and I've done some uh small
group where I'll start some say a group
of 10 people here in the club and I'll
take them through a six-month program
and it's nutrition coaching but to take
that same program and reach out to I
mean Toyota's just 10 miles north of me
in Frisco they had a few employees what
if I was INSP instead of speaking to 10
people here once a month I'm speaking to
a thousand people once a month via
Toyota or Dr Pepper or I mean I'm
surrounded in the North Dallas area with
all these big companies
it's a game I've never played but as a
manufacturer in the in the past I used
to do presentations to much larger
groups than I mean that's just part of
my job so it's I'm not afraid of it I
can do it I've just never done it before
and it would seem like there would be an
opportunity because people are
struggling with their health I mean they
are right so I'm going to challenge you
he said you know you're thinking about
Toyota in them and you said you've never
done it before is that true
because you actually do
I've never done it on that scale that's
I've never played that game right but
you you've done it because you're doing
it with the people in in your in your
world right now correct yes or that's
true oh so one thing I would encourage
you to do is don't make those people
special don't make Toyota special don't
have them on a pedestal I worked at a
non-profit and as I transitioned into
coaching years ago I came back to the
non-profit and said listen I'm leaving
but you guys have been really great and
I'd like to do a pilot program and I did
like a a four-week pilot program they
loved it and they became my first
corporate client they were the ones
right who became my first corporate
client and then I built from there and
then every company Morgan Stanley
wherever I went after that was built on
what I did in that non-profit so what I
want to encourage you is what you're
doing right now
it's not going to be it doesn't need to
be any different for Toyota like you
want Master what you're doing there and
just BR and and how you do that is you
you fall in love with the people you're
doing a lifetime like it is Toyota you
show up that's the game now and then
every company I've got uh I've gotten
into initially the internet will help
you and Evan will help you in that way
but you also I always ask the question
where client says who do you know who
right who do you know who and just right
who do I if I want to get in Toyota who
do I know who works for Toyota who do I
know who's in that industry if I want to
write a book who do I know who wrote a
book and then get in their world
get in conversation in their world ask
them questions tell them what you're up
to and then you want to create what
you've been doing in lifetime the
biggest mistake people make is they
don't create context they think because
they've been doing something they meet
someone they know what they're up to no
you want to slow down and and you talk
to the person from Toyota and say and
they say well what are you up to and you
say
I'm glad you asked man I'm so excited
I've been doing this group a lifetime
I'm going to be taking it all over the
world to different companies and you
know and then you want to create a
win-win for that person in Toyota hey
who how can we uh get me in front of
someone and I promise they're going to
be thanking you for bringing me in thank
you The Smiling why are you smiling
because I'm excited yeah yeah so so good
what are you most excited about
the opportunity I mean I just started
this a couple of weeks ago so I'm brand
new yeah so so a couple things you want
to really be a master in what you're
doing at Lifetime right and and treat it
like you're a Toyota wherever you want
to be right and and understand that
don't put them on a pedestal
because once you kind of put them on a
pedestal I remember I was going to work
with Morgan Stanley one of my first
companies and I had put them on a
pedestal and and uh I was like oh man
you know Morgan Stanley and my coach
said I want you to watch this movie
right so he he says okay so he sends me
The Big Short right so now I'm like I
don't even know oh my God I don't even
know if I want to work with these guys
right but what it does is it load the
bot and when I spoke to them they could
understand I was just there to serve
them they need me more than I need them
so the second thing the third thing I'm
going to tell you is write that question
down who do I know who and it doesn't
have to be someone who directly works
for Toyota it could be someone who knows
someone and you want to start creating
with them you don't just say hey can you
connect me with Toyota you want to
create the context hey I'm doing this
amazing thing in lifetime I serve 10
people every four months and and this is
some of the transformation that's
happened in their life and I'd love to
get to Toyota and talk to someone in
Toyota to bring that there and make you
look good that's that's how you could
build the bridge that was one of the
biggest things I struggled with too in
terms of helping people it's like oh my
God it's this person they're so well
known and like they have all they've
done all this stuff I'm speaking after
this person like Hannah Montana that
this person and that that held me back
for so long and then I realized no I'm
like I'm Kick-Ass at what I do and I
know more about my thing that they know
about my thing like they might be good
at their thing but I know more about my
thing than they do and once I flip that
I was like oh no I can go in like any
anybody's YouTube channel anybody is
thought leadership I'll come in and I
have something to contribute yeah right
yeah and I just know that going in
without even having seen it yep you know
like anybody I'll go look like here's
what you can do to grow you see that
shift the shift is you remembered who
you were being it's like I'm the best at
what I do yeah they don't know what I do
that's a way of being that's a way of
stepping in yeah and that's what we're
talking that took me like yeah I a
decade right right I mean like you guys
get that now as you hear way ahead of me
it took me so long to get there and
that's the point it takes sometimes you
know a decade to get there but like now
if we focus on retraining your thoughts
so that you have that way of being now
it saves you 10 no 100 yeah and also
being like you guys being here in the
community of other people learning like
reinforces it let's bring up Mary so
Devin um I'm actually working with uh
Evan more closely and
um he has this amazing strategy or where
he said you know if you want to be a
thought leader if you want to get
clients I'm a coach I'm a certified
professional coach and I've decided that
my specialization mindset because it's
extremely a fascinating field and I
think that that's everything starts with
a thought it's the first thing that we
start with so that's that's where I'd
like to um focus my my interests in
coaching so um so what we're what I'm
doing is I'm following success snap
which is that you know you bring on
people that you can interview who could
be your client or who could refer
clients to you as a way of trying to get
clients my immediate goal is to get four
clients this year so that I can replace
my income and leave my job to do
coaching
so knowing what you know now and then
you know given your incredible expertise
what advice would you give to someone
like to to someone like me who's
currently basically doing this part-time
so that I can transition to it full-time
in January great question first of all
my first advice would be keep hanging
with this guy oh yeah really I love that
he's the real deal
yeah either be his shadow like because
you know I always say I'm here because I
stand on the shoulders of giants right
like I I really learned from the best in
the business and this guy's the best in
the business now I love where you at
work are at because I was there at one
point right so I had uh three children
and I was at this non-profit and I I had
gotten this promotion and it wasn't what
I want to do anymore even though it was
a promotion and I went to my coach and I
said
I don't know I'm a entrepreneur I've
been watching Mark Cuban right I was
like how can I call myself a coach when
when I have a part-time job does that
resonate you know what I mean oh yeah
then I said oh no I gotta make the big
leap right and and and I just got to
quit and start from scratch and he said
hold on Devin he said you got three kids
he said he said you can make the big
leap that's one way people do it he said
or you can build a bridge
and he said if you build a bridge and
serve the people so much that you make
and you build your practice it'll be so
uncomfortable that you'll have to quit
your job and that was a way better way
for me because you know I had to put
some money on the table so making the
big leap is it for everyone so I love
what you're doing because the benefit of
you having a job and have an income come
in is that you're not as needy for money
and and my coach used to tell me that
needy is creepy so we don't want to be
creepy in coaching conversations now in
addition to following Evan
you know one of the things I used to say
I I come with a spreadsheet I need eight
clients at this I need two speaking and
my coach would say no you don't
you only need one and I said what you're
gonna that's why you're so great you're
gonna teach me how to get one client and
make all this money said no no you just
need the next one
he said if you treat
every enrollment conversation as the
most important conversation you could
ever be in and you just say president
serve those people and then the next one
then the next one you will grow by
serving them so how I started early with
is that
I stopped listening to music for a year
because everything I listened to was
about coaching and development on the
train like when I went to work and then
every moment I had after work I had
enrollment calls on lunch breaks I I
would go I remember being in a Burger
King parking lot one time like and and
all kinds of stuff so what what you want
to do is raise your level and you seem
like a highly committed woman but raise
your level of commitment to like this is
what you look I could tell you love
coaching so it I loved it so much that
it was like I want to fill my calendar
with as many enrollment conversations as
possible and then you'll build your
practice the only thing that will get
you there from my opinion other than the
help with Evan is time and attention
most people don't put enough time and
attention into their coaching so I get
off work and then I spend some time with
the kids and then everything else my
first client was a client from
California I'm in New York she was a
teacher she got off at 7 30. I think I
was charging her
it was hour and a half every single week
for like 400 a month right it was like
400 but but but and check this out and
she got home at 7 30 Pacific so I was
coaching her once a week from 10 30 at
night till 12 but you know it was more
important than the money I I started
getting the Reps in as being a better
Coach so I would serve I would serve it
and then it became fun and then all of a
sudden I looked around and I had five
six people it was I was making more
money part-time as a coach than I was in
my full-time and then like I said my my
job became my full-time
um my first corporate client you're
right and it's and it's it's to the
prosperous coach of like serving that
one client it's one client a client at a
time yeah no that that certainly helps
and you'll scale way faster than me and
I I scale pretty fast because you have
that but you also have the I didn't have
an Evan in my life then so it probably
would have took a little like double
like quick quicker if I had Evan too so
it's like I did it this way and and I
scale really quick because I just fell
in love and served people but with Evan
you know you're gonna four times the the
acceleration so be a great coach serve
people and really get them in
conversations now you have one
conversation and that you think that
like their
uh they're on the On The Fringe but
they're not sure right there's nothing
wrong with slowing it down and saying
Hey I want to do something with you I'm
going to give you one more conversation
just to see if this works you can never
there's no
wrong way to go when you're in service
with others sir
yeah absolutely I could just ask follow
on that show because we do it is we have
a YouTube channel and then we bring on
entrepreneurs and people who would be
our ideal clients or people who could
refer us to some ideal clients yeah so
I've got someone that'll be coming on my
channel who's like an entrepreneur a
lawyer very very successful and my
question is as I interview her a book or
entrepreneurial Journey ask her some
mindset related questions to sort of
interject that I'm a coach so that she
knows like what would be the best
strategy of of connecting like you know
talking about the thing without talking
about the thing talking about how I am a
coach that really pitching an enrollment
conversation to her because that's not
the intention of the interview
um but it's also like to kind of
showcase her also give her an idea about
what I could offer or people that she
know to me the most important thing
about that interview is that you show up
powerfully and serve her right and
culture yes subtly you could say what
you're up to I think that camera
conversation happens after right I think
that after you say Hey you know based on
what you said see people don't do this
they're not direct with people it's like
what I want to do what I do with some of
my special guests just some of my
special guests I give them a 90-minute
coaching session are you open to have
like I want to give that to you so now
it's all in service to them you give
them the 90-minute session and now
you're in their world and they're
getting the experience of you coaching
yeah they got the YouTube experience but
now they have more of an intimate
experience and if they get that part of
you they're going to be more likely to
say I want more absolutely I am going to
implement that thank you and just to add
uh when you're doing we call that a Biz
Dev show you're doing the show just
trying to trying to get business coming
in people are signing up thinking you're
going to interview them and so we don't
want to flip it to be a coaching show
because we I didn't know you were going
to coach me we had fun with that but a
lot of people won't be that open to say
I thought you were interviewing me why
are you at why are you trying to Now
give me advice right that's not why
they're coming on right so we just need
to be able to touch on the fact that you
are a coach for that what you do and and
say in my practice what I see a lot of
as a mindset coach in my practice what I
see is people struggle with mindset
living beliefs Etc how do you see that
happening in your business right and
then you have a conversation around it
yeah but you've introduced your mindset
coach without trying to be her mindset
coach in the moment the other thing I
mean we've been going back a little bit
on the Discord on this and in the master
my Discord uh when you are reaching out
to somebody to his point about dalt um
what did you say like don't they're not
any different or what yeah don't put
them on a pedal sort of kind of stuff in
the Outreach to her you had something
like I uh you're so inspiring or I love
you so like you're you're already
separating yourself right as opposed to
I'd love to have you on my show to share
your message with my audience
instead of I'm So inspired by you
because if you're inspired by them now
you're putting them up above you and
they're putting them above you which
then they don't think uh I'm not going
to hire this person to coach me if
they're inspired by me right it's like
not Pluto I want to have the guy who
might Devin might appreciate all the
things that I've done but still kick my
ass on like dude like what are you doing
you're playing small right if you're
trying to have her be a client then the
positioning matters at the beginning if
you're hoping that she refers you to
other people then it's not as big a deal
but just that positioning in the wording
and how you set it up and I love his
point too but like show up powerfully
show up as you are already a kick-ass
coach because you want your guests to be
like how do you have that magic you know
like I want I want to be in that magic
more and I want to send my clients to
YouTube so in other words show up in
your beat yeah
absolutely because people watching will
remember like that's what they'll you'll
start getting people who just want to
see more of you and you know gifting
someone when you see someone you want to
work with gifting them a complimentary
session so they can experience you is
the best way to go when vacuum cleaners
first came out you know the story no I
don't know maybe the vacuum cleaners
people were selling vacuum cleaners and
and when they first came out nobody
wanted vacuum clean so the rate of
conversion of vacuum cleaners was like
seven percent then there was this one
guy who was who was serving like people
at like at 85 clip so they watched so
with the normal vacuum cleaner seller
would do was he'd show up at the door
and talk about all the features and the
benefits of the vacuum cleaner and
they'd be like get out of here we don't
want it we don't want it now the guy who
sold it at a 85 clip would show up with
no vacuum cleaner and he'd say hey can I
come in your living room and he come in
the living room and there'd be a white
rug and he'd reach in his pocket it and
he pull out dirt and he just drop it
on the dirt and smear it and the people
would freak out they'd be like what's
wrong with you and how could you do that
and he said hold on then he'd go to his
car and get the vacuum cleaner and he
vacuum it up the difference is one was
was pushing their features and their
benefits the other gave them the
experience
and when you invite people to a
complimentary session or or gifted
session they will get the experience of
you give them an experience of coaching
not the features and benefits you give
people The Experience they're going to
want more and say wow if we could if I
think differently like that in 60
minutes 90 minutes imagine what six
months in a year would be give them the
experience yeah we call this uh last
time in the in Movie Makers about the
guy who created the bulletproof vest
couldn't talk about it like people
couldn't wrap their head around it and
so it was making no sales right so he
went to a police station at the shooting
range took out a gun and fired it on
himself and and then a lot back up right
and it's like it works oh and so they
then bought because how do you explain
the bulletproof vest well let's just
show it yeah that's great so Margaret
you're up next
um my question is I'm from New York City
I'm from LeBron and I'm a first
responder
um I've been on my job for 22 years and
I have four years left now in 2020 I did
higher life coach I invested in myself
and now I feel out of place here and I'm
like but I have four years left here
yeah so retired to get my full pension
I do want to go into the coaching
business I have been narrowed down my
Niche because
I have so many people I want to inspire
but I know I have to narrow down so like
one audience
um my question for you is um how did you
stay confident knowing you're from
Queens and
like knowing that like people will like
judge you or you know like you said
well I I'm confident because I'm from
cool from Queens not because I'm not now
it's funny
now I know about the Boogie that I used
to actually work in the Bronx that was
where the non-profit was on uh in South
in the South Bronx on 53rd and Third
Avenue so I acknowledge you for being a
first responder first of all thank you
for your service in the world you know
um you know it's funny
we have four years left
right and the issue is never the issue
the issue is in four years
the issue is how you relate to the issue
it's how you relate to the four years so
you could you could look at these four
years as man I I gotta wake up every day
and get to the end well you could wake
up every day excite say man I got I got
a four year run so I got this pension I
got some time where I could create my
business and fall in love with these
next four years rather than dreading it
that's the first thing I would say I
work with people who are Rikers Island
um before and and you know they did
studies and you know when people go to
jail they have good time right you know
so you do a year you you could get off
in like 10 months if you have a good
time okay if you do 10 years you can get
off an eight if you if you don't mess up
and what they found was ninety percent
of the guys who lost their good time
lost it in the last 30 days before they
were gonna get out wow right because
what happened was they saw the light at
the end of the tunnel and the things
they were patient with before they just
weren't patient and they get in fights
so don't do that don't do that
right don't say oh my God and what
happens is if I start dreading my four
years
it'll start your way of being at work
will start being you know like
dismissive and and like impatient so we
want to first fall in love with the next
four years and say hey this is a road a
road map for me to do what I want to do
next and you know I would first thing if
you want to be a coach to me the best
book on coaching is the prosperous coach
it really teaches you how to be one a
great coach but also make a business of
coaching like Zen said earlier and as
far as your Niche you know I used to say
Niche and then I traveled lately and I
he's so yeah and I've almost arrived
yeah yeah I'm plenty I'm fancy now now
sometimes you can you know
um dial down your Niche however
what I say is sometimes you gotta let
your Niche find you
so you just commit to serving people
like when I worked with just for fathers
at first I wrote a book called father at
his leadership I worked with fathers who
were really successful and and one of my
oldest clients she's my longest standing
client over 10 years she was a a doctor
uh she did shoulder surgery on my
shoulder she used to do like sports
medicine sir she's a top 40 under 40 at
the time and she asked me she said uh I
need a coach to you no one and I was
like Blake Shelton I was like this hello
you know from The Voice and she laughed
at me she was like Devin you're my
patient you do that thing with fathers
and the moment I was like wow she's
right what does that mean about my niche
but I knew and I knew I could help him
so I said yeah I work with fathers and
are you open
and I had a conversation with I had two
conversations she became my first client
and she's still my client 10 over 10
years later so don't get so caught up in
your Niche you you can go all after a
niche but I wouldn't wait for it start
serving people and sometimes if you
serve people your Niche will certain
it's fine you faster people every day
here like I use practice here especially
with like the young girls coming in at
Southern views don't let this job use
you use dumb as you find your passion
your purpose like I have one young lady
she's back in nursing school like so I
try to inspire people yeah like I don't
want them to ever I feel like this job
lose you lose your creativity here you
lose the imagination you become
conditioned and I'm so glad that I
invested in the coach because I would
not ever saw that I would have never
wanted to do all this that I'm doing now
and it started wearing my daughter but
now
like I'm ready I I acknowledge look
you're a first responder the work you do
to me is like
truly God's work like you you really are
extraordinary the here's the question I
have for you if you want more creativity
at your job who do you need to be
supervisor first time just laugh right
what more creative
see if I'm working with a cut and uh a
couple and they say
oh I don't feel the love if you want
more love in your relationship who do
you need to be more loving if you want
more acknowledgment in your relationship
who do you need to be more acknowledging
if I want more creativity in my job what
do I need to be more creative don't wait
for those people to be creative because
you'll be waiting for four years you
have something wrong with the gift
Carlene is up next let's go Carlene so I
had a little bit of a different angle to
ask you about just being in the NBA
World especially I'm my son's fascinated
with all things NBA and soccer Etc my
other son
um so obviously I love coaching
um I think it's so valuable obviously
and I also have been getting into the
world of what we can't see and our body
uh what we keep in our body in terms of
energy so I I'm a pharmacist by trade
I'm in hospice so uh I came from a very
logical background and then now getting
into energy healing and in particular
looking at the heart and the walls that
the heart builds around it as protection
in the form of energy or emotions and
I've been using a technique that I found
really powerful to allow
um
people to really tap into that energy of
the heart and what has been a dream of
mine for a very long time
um has been to get with
professional athletes and not only
help them release their heart wall for
themselves and their athletic
performance but also
this kind of seems silly but like with
their animal to release it with their
animal because it allows them an
experience of pure love I feel like when
both them and their animal can be that
connected and I was just curious how you
would
like how would you
see a way into that were like a doorway
into professional
um
so I love I love what you're up to now
do you like fascia do you study like the
consciousness of like in in us so what
they found is in your body is this
protective wall like fascia that is kind
of what they found was it actually
thinks like there's Consciousness within
your body so this energy that you talk
about is is a really powerful way to to
serve and deliver to people
um so you're saying what's the doorway
into the sports world
yeah and I haven't made my land well
well you know somebody's in the NBA now
so that's one way to like who do you
know who and Evan brought me on so you
know I I'd be willing to have a
conversation with you as somebody who's
a a guest uh I mean a part of the group
with Evan
um you know when I got in the Sports
World I I played college basketball
and I was kind of like uh retired you
play at a high level sometimes you go
one of two ways either you stay in it
forever or you like I played I'm done
right and so
um you know I I was like out of the
Sports World for a while and then my
youngest son which they call Swish he he
gave me the they gave me the guilt trip
uh and he said you know you coached my
older brother and now you want to retire
and now coach you got to coach me so now
I got back into coaching because he gave
me the guilt trip and I really uh I was
around conversations and and I had just
built relationships over the years and
even later on
um just by getting in conversations with
people so I would ask the question who
do I know who and sometimes you it's not
about knocking on one door to get in the
NBA it's really about creating yourself
everywhere you go so every conversation
you have when people are asking you what
you're up to it's like I'm real what I'm
doing is I'm creating this modality
where I serve uh athletes with you know
from their heart center and their
energies you want to create yourself
everywhere you go because what will
happen is you think the door is over
here but it'll be a conversation you
have in Target where someone says hey uh
my brother works you know works for you
know the best high school team best
soccer high school team in the country
you want to can I can I connect you now
you connect with them and then you keep
serving so it's not about like capturing
the big dog it's about who are you
serving along the way and um now I work
at this this uh the number one high
school in the country called montverde
high school this is they gave me a shirt
and I'm the go-to Mind coach for them so
they bring me in and and they send about
five or six athletes to the NBA every
year from high school right like they
did like the the real deal
um and so and that's some of my most
rewarding work like I love the guys you
know in the league but like young people
and getting them early and then what
happens is I serve these young people
early they end up getting in the league
and I'm in their world their whole life
so so what I would encourage you to get
in really a high level of service and
and and really start letting people know
that that's what you do that's who you
are I'm the number one heart Healy I'm
not heart healing energy coach for that
for world-class athletes
be that that's funny because it came out
in the last in the two weeks and it's
like I have so many different
ways that I truly know that I meant to
serve it's so it's sounds like I'm gonna
have a four and a half minute pitch as
well yeah and it's just you who you show
up as if you step into that what happens
is you may go to a soccer game with your
son and you're missing all the
opportunity because you're going there
kind of like the shrunken nut I'm not
this thing right not just you anyone but
if I'm walking in as like hey I'm the
go-to heart healing energy coach of
world class athletes and I'm not at the
soccer game you tell somebody and
they'll be like oh really listen I got a
cousin he's a world-class side to play
he needs you and I connect you but if
you're if you're not letting people know
who you are
you'll never you'll never get what you
want and to go a little more meta for
everybody I don't know if you guys all
notice but just to witness Devin's great
coaching our last caller was from New
York and Devin got so loud like this guy
is loud right it's like it's a whole
level of loud from him and then Carlene
comes on it's like a a much softer
gentler vibe that she was putting out
and then you just drop in and are
instantly softer and gentle it's just
he's not the same everywhere he goes
it's like it's a dance right and that's
what great coaching is as well because
if he's showing up yelling at Carlene
it's not gonna it's not gonna work as
well so you just gotta take a much
softer approach right so like if you
want to watch replay just go back and
watch those last two calls back to back
the advice is great but also how he was
his being was different depending on the
and and you've shipped it every time
we've had different people on but I
think that was the most noticeable
difference
that's right right and so just it's
worth watching back to see how you need
to show up to be a great coach for your
clients
uh and okay I think we have time for one
more let's bring up Amma and see what
she's got for us
um I'm curious to see how you're going
to be Devin from the UK I'm here in
London on a British accent so hello uh
first of all hi everyone this is what I
love about my UK people right that you
know my lady and she's from Australia
but lived in Scotland most of the life
right and they in New York we call it
talking smack but in in in London they
call it top banter right they call it
banter right so what I love about my
London people is they're highly
skeptical so when I at first but they're
open so when I go when I go to the game
changer really quick and I say who's
skeptical at first in New York you know
you'll get about six seven people I'm
skeptical this one in La you'll only get
three because they're always fronting it
first in LA and I love LA and then in
London you got half the room and I
remember I was in London and Game
Changer I said who's skeptical and this
guy was like me yes and look at this
time zone and and I said why are you
skeptical he said well
I just think this may be American luster
right and I love this right and it was
great and those are like the people I
love because you don't have to be a
believer it's like you're skepticism
just be open and then we can create a
miracle so sorry to interrupt let's go
I'm a confidence coach for mothers and I
help build the confidence of mothers
who've had time off to raise their
family or
um to just take a career break to
re-enter the workspace or they've been
in the corporate world for some time and
they just don't have the confidence to
start that passion product project like
me I worked in my background is in
marketing and public relations I worked
with the airlines for 20 years and I was
really scared to really follow my heart
which was to impact people and support
people and build them while they're in
transition and I know what that
transition is like because I was the
same as a mother
my question to you is you said wake up
in the morning in the first 90 minutes
do the most important thing but as a
startup coach Everything feels important
you know your content your lives your
Outreach calling people how do you know
what to prioritize as your most
important thing when you're new at the
game but your mouth is open like your
grandmother said and the mouth that is
open gets fed because I definitely want
to be fed great question
um so one of the things I just want to
be clear is you know as I move in before
I start my most important things the
actual first most important thing is my
self-care so I have a morning routine
that where I fill my cup so that before
I go and serve and respond to anything
I'm serving from an overflow cup and not
from an empty cup so that's number one
now when like you said when you start up
when there's a startup and you know you
really
figuring out which is the one do I focus
on it could be a little confusing at
first you know in the beginning of any
startup it's be willing to be a little
messy right don't be willing like don't
look for Perfection right so for me
there are certain things that you want
to really dial down which is what I call
money making activities
because a lot of people do a lot of like
hey you know I'm gonna go and respond in
Facebook and and connect with people but
but none of that is bringing money in
and and you have a profession so part of
the MIT is like Evan looked and said for
me to move towards 35 million I really
need to start looking at what I need to
say no to
and and so one of the practices I would
encourage you is to look in your world
and say where do I need to say no
right because
um Warren Buffett one of my favorite
quotes from Warren Buffett is busy is
the new stupid
right so so we don't so that's one of my
very good now now we're gonna do one
right now
yeah and and so sometimes people have
to-do lists and I encourage people to
say hey what's on your to don't list
right and and one
I have three cornerstones right
um and so the lens of which I say no I
say Warren Buffett also said they said
what's the key to your success he said I
say no 90 of the time and what he means
is no to the things that are less of a
priority because when I'm saying yes to
things that are lower priorities at the
expense of the things at the higher
priority so when people say Devin I
don't know what to do my time and people
say uh do you relate to a time
management issue
okay so that's great because does
anybody relate to a time management
issue I have a time management issue all
right if someone's saying that the first
thing I'll look in is you don't have a
time management issue you have a
people-pleasing issue you're saying yes
to too many things that you need to say
no to so for you it's like what's the
most important three things in your
business right now the three most
important I think is awareness I need to
let as many people know that I am a
coach I've transitioned and that's going
through my contact list and following my
personal friends and people that I know
to say that I'm this is what I'm doing
now and if there's any opportunity to
serve them invite them for a Clarity
call on something that I can support
them with or maybe ask them to refer me
to somebody that might need my services
okay the second thing will be
um
on a daily basis practicing what I
preach right so as a man like you said I
make sure that I have time in the
morning to serve myself because my life
really is my marketing so I try to bring
my Evans told us to have our cameras
around and post that regularly on our
stories showing that I am a mom I'd go
through the struggle I understand it and
these are the practices that I believe
in and I'm practicing and it's working
for me and I think that that thing is to
do one uncomfortable thing a day and
usually for me is around reaching out to
like Partners here to collaborate or go
live or
um do something that I wouldn't
ordinarily do so find something that
challenges me every day to step into I
love that so you it's great you're a
Clarity coach because you're very clear
right so that's very so here's the thing
if I ask you and EV uh you to show me
and Evan your calendar would I see those
three things in your calendar the first
thing I'll ask clients is show me a
calendar because I say what is the most
important things oh my family is and
then I say where's the family time in
your account calendar so for me you
wanna I have three cornerstones this is
my assignment on this were in in the
world it's like I'm gonna love as many
people that I can before I die and
that's number one two when it's all said
and done uh they're gonna say I used
every bit of talent that was left I left
it all on the court I'm not leaving with
anything left and uh serving people
through this work so that's the three
cornerstones in my assignments of this
world and so everything that comes into
me as Auto requests goes through those
three lenses and it fits in so when
people see me they say you're so busy I
said I'm the least busy person in the
world you're gonna always see me doing
one of these three things you won't
catch me in the club ain't nothing wrong
with the club but it's not in service to
the three things of my assignments so
that's what I like to say and I'd also
like to acknowledge you man you are such
a beacon of a bright light in the world
of service and impact and and I could
tell by like these amazing people that
you have in your community so I just
want to tell you you know I really
appreciate who you are who can be in the
world and thank you for having me on
thank you man
you haven't been innocent in the house
where people want to find out more about
you where do you want them to go just
devinvandison.com and uh check out my
game changer experience I hope to see
one of you in one of those weekends if
you want to join us in movement makers
check the link in the description below
otherwise enjoy this video right here I
think you'll love it